we are looking at bingo today let me
just remind you of how normal bingo
works right normal bingo actually can
anyone explain to me how does normal
bingo work here tom you have like a
certain numbers
yep somewhere on the front drawing
around
yeah very good so that's that's that's
perfect so if i just gave you a simple
example okay um i'll just do three
because it'll be quicker
you have like a bingo card okay um which
retirees around the world are just sort
of sitting there and you know
um they've got their card in front of
them everyone's got a different set of
numbers on their card
and then the announcer at the front
we'll call you know we'll have for
example we'll have dice or some other
like drawing it out of a hat and we'll
roll it and say
it's a it's a four and then if you're
like oh i've got a four you know you get
excited you cross it out okay and we
keep playing and then as tom said
usually it's like can you get three in a
row or three in a column or a diagonal
whatever and then you call out
bingo hooray and then you've won right
now we're gonna play bingo but we're
gonna play a little bit different
because this is um this is boring bingo
there's no there's no
um nothing interesting to it and you
have no control it's completely random
i'm not gonna make any um
it's not sexist i guess it'd be ageist
aegis statement anyway i who knows when
i'm a retiree i might play bingo too
we're going to play
subtractor bingo all right now i'm going
to show you how it works and you might
notice your cards
you've got a few of them they're blank
unlike normal bingo you just get handed
a card and like look at the draw
literally okay here you actually get
some power here so let me explain the
way it works i'm subtracting bingo i'm
gonna have two dice okay
and um i'm gonna roll them okay there's
a blue and green and i'm gonna read out
a number or you guys can actually tell
me the number yourselves right which is
i'm gonna take one away from the other
okay i will take the smaller one away
from the bigger one so maybe this is a
bad example let's just do it again okay
so three and one
so i'm gonna subtract them one
from three which leaves me with
two so if i had two on my card i'd cross
out two okay now you can probably work
out pretty quickly
it's a six and a four so then again
it'll be a two
sorry do one more as an example there
you go six in a two so it's going to be
four
okay
so you can see here that the smallest
number that's possible is if i had
two are the same there when i subtract
them i'm gonna get
zero very good okay the biggest possible
number i won't be able to go up to nine
will i how far can i go
five very good okay you can actually see
it i put it under your sheet there just
in case you missed that five's the
highest because i need a six and a one
there you go or vice versa i suppose uh
one and a six still going to subtract it
yeah
okay so here's where the catch comes in
you get to design craft your own card
now you have a look if you count you'll
see along the top here we'll do a few
rounds that's why there's so many rows
there are 12 numbers that i want you to
choose i want you to choose 12 numbers
now you only have five to choose from so
some of them are going to be repeated
perhaps you are going to write down i'll
just give you an example okay you might
say i like the number three so i'm gonna
have four threes okay uh maybe a one
uh two
five for good measure chuck in a couple
of zeros you can put them in any order
you like maybe like no i'm just gonna
have another three just because i want
to okay so obviously you're going to
have some repeats if you're going to
have all 12 numbers now unlike me
it'll probably be easier for you to tick
off your card and win faster if maybe
you put it in like some kind of order
ascending order descending order doesn't
matter really so what i'm going to get
you to do now i'll give you a couple
minutes to think about it and then to
write down your set of your first set of
12 numbers don't write down several
rounds
after your first round i'll let you have
a think about how you went and how you
might adjust the card you design
so i'll give you a couple minutes to
think about that